hello everyone and welcome to the only
game ever played
as far as uh you know we know uh between
bill gates and magnus carlson
yesterday was a rest day at the tata
steel so i decided to show something uh
something short or something a bit more
interesting as we are
going to have some very exhausting games
today so it's a game that took in uh
place in 2014 uh on the uh show of the
host
skovland so scotland is a norwegian
swedish uh television talk show hosted
by
norwegian journalist fredericks calvin
and uh in the show
they asked bill gates if he's okay
playing against magnus cross and i will
put a link to it in the description
below it's some 18 minute clip if you
want to check it out
bill gates talk talks a lot about his
ventures about his philanthropy and what
not
and then at the end of that they play a
game of chess and
when they ask magnus uh how will they
play will will there be clocks will
there be what will be the time control
uh magnus said uh i will have 30 seconds
and you can have
all the time you want so he doesn't
really care
and in the end they agreed that magnus
will have 30 seconds and bill gates will
have two minutes on the clock
now i've always known of this game but i
i only today realized that i have no
idea how the game goes and that i don't
even know the move so
uh without further ado without further
ado uh
let's uh check out this game so bill
gates uh with the white pieces opens
with
e4 and we even have a nice uh image of
this moment so let's check that out
there you have it
uh that's the setting of the talk show
uh bill gates placed his pawn on e4
and now the game starts magnus replies
with
knight to c6 and one thing magnus also
needs to take into consideration
is that he only has 30 seconds on the
clock so it doesn't matter if you get a
good position if you're not going to
have enough time on the clock to
finish the game and if you play uh on
your pc
and you use a mouse 30 seconds also
known as hyper bullet
uh can be plenty of time if you've ever
seen the penguin or
andrew tang play a bullet you know that
30 30 seconds is enough for him to
finish like 10 games
but in actual over the board chess it
takes you time to pick up the piece uh
put the piece down hit the clock so you
will lose at least uh one second on the
move unless you're like super fast
so here knights the c6 magnus goes for
the nimsovich defense we have knight f3
by gates
and now magnus goes d5 immediately
strikes in the center
and when he played d5 he knocked over uh
uh bill's e4 pawn and then he lost a few
seconds
rearranging the board but you know what
are you gonna do uh we have bishop to d3
now he could capture or he could advance
the pawn
uh he could also defend it not not all
that great he decides to do it with
bishop to d3
so very very interesting approach uh we
have knight to f6
with a double attack on the pawn and
only now he captures we have captures
captures and here
knight to c3 so developing with tempo
you can see that uh
bill gates knows what he's doing uh
pushes back the black queen and magnus
goes queen to h5
so what do you do here uh bill gates
castles uh and
magnus uh develops by pinning the knight
so bishop to g4
and you can see that a lot of things are
starting to happen here on the king side
uh gates should be very careful about
what he is doing bishop to e2 might be a
nice safe move making room for the
d-pawn
uh he decides to challenge carlson's
bishop with h3 and here like i said
magnus is very low on time
not very low he started with 30 seconds
he's down to some maybe
23 seconds up to this point uh and now
he needs to decide what to do with the
bishop of course
if this was a normal game you would
capture and after captures captures you
will have ruined white's pawn structure
you have a better position you will
eventually probably win this game but uh
magnus cannot afford to go into some
sort of a slow game he needs to go for
checkmate
so he goes in knight to e5 he decides to
sacrifice the bishop here
and it's not the greatest of moves but
it is the greatest of moose for the
occasion so bill gates uh
boldly captures the bishop h captures on
g4
and this is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine so it's not a
not uh some sort of a uh you know a
silly silly piece grab
uh we have knight f captures on g4 by
magnus
and now we have this position where
magnus has a lot of pieces in front of
the white king and white should be very
careful one thing
that you have to realize is that if this
knight moves or is captured queen here
will be checkmate
so one move that comes to mind is rook
to e1 with rook to e1
uh bill gates gets uh enough for for a
winning advantage
of course that's easier said than done
uh when you have he also has uh
only two minutes from the start of the
game and he is playing the world
champion as this is 2014 magnus is
already world champion
and here even if you go for captures
captures and queen h2 check you will not
be delivering checkmate because now you
have king to f1
and after queen h1 check king the e2
there's nowhere for for the black queen
to go the queen is under attack and also
the knight is under
attack and even if you guard it let's
say you play something like this
uh you allow bishop to b5 check and then
it's just game over
for example if c6 you can just capture
this captures captures with
check king d8 captures with check
again uh just f3 keeping the white king
safe and the white is up too much
material of course white will be
completely winning here
however after this knight f the g4 move
bill gates did not play rook to e1 or
some safe move bishop to b5 check he in
fact just
grabbed the knight knight captures on e5
and he missed
the simplest of ideas uh which is of
course
queen to h2 checkmate this is what
magnus played
and he stopped the time at this exact
same moment
and in the end bill gates had some a
minute and 10 seconds on the clock
whereas magnus carlsen uh had some 18
seconds on the clock
he delivered checkmate on 20 seconds and
then when he paused the clock it was
like 18 seconds
so bill gates played a great game here
if anyone you know was interested
uh he just uh missed a crucial move uh
at a crucial
point as i i think he also got super
nervous
and uh he just couldn't uh you know
think straight
uh but even before the game started he
he said that he was a much more of a go
player
than a chess player so very interesting
uh i don't know if any of you are into
gold maybe you know of some
bill gates go games uh but yeah that's
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it
uh i've always known about this game but
i've never actually seen it
and i i've always been like yeah
everyone knows of this game but then
today i realized i don't know of this
game so if any of you didn't know of
this game also
uh there you have it this is what
happened when magnus uh faced bill gates
and like i said uh one week prior to the
to this he faced mark zuckerberg uh but
we do not have uh
uh moves to this game or maybe
they say was a game but maybe it was
more of a lesson so
i don't know if any of you guys can
check it can spot the moves of
of those games maybe even share it so we
can show that one as well
uh but yeah that's basically it hope you
guys enjoyed it i will put a link in the
description below to the entire
live live uh footage of this game so if
you want to check that out
as well i would like to thank joshua
hampson
uh yasmin had rich moti marco and scott
rooks for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
the coverage of the tata still checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day